[Music]
the art of motherhood to teach a child
the art of life
the best place for Tears is a mother's
hugs
[Music]
mothers hurt even more when you heard
everything around is changing but only
mother remains mother
[Music]
a mother who was really a mother is
never free
Mother's Love is the only love from
which there's no betrayal
mothers hold children's hands for a
short time but their hearts forever
[Music]
mother is the most beautiful word a
person can utter
mother is the name of God on their lips
and in the hearts of little children
[Music]
everything beautiful in a person comes
from the sun's rays and from mother's
milk
children are the anchors that keep a
mother alive
the only love I believe in is the love
of a mother for a child
the future of the nation is in the hands
of its mothers
foreign
there is nothing that A Mother's Love
cannot endure
[Music]
The Hand That Rocks the Cradle rules the
world
[Music]
when a woman becomes a mother she
forever deprives herself of the right to
be weak
you will not stop being a child as long
as you have a mother
[Music]
God couldn't be everywhere so he created
mothers
[Music]
a child recognizes its mother by her
smile
[Music]
the song that a mother sings at the
Cradle accompanies a person all his life
until the grave
[Music]
mom's hands are woven from tenderness
mom's love is a cozy Courtyard always
warm and sunny
moms are always there to help even when
they are not around
mom is a person who can replace everyone
but no one can replace her
give us the best Mothers and we will
give you the best people
foreign
the more people I get to know the more I
love my mom
mother is the heartbeat of the home
nothing is lost while your mom is
looking for it
[Music]
mom is one word three letters
Eternal meaning
[Music]
mom is the most expensive luxury in the
world appreciate her
[Music]
mom is a wonder of the world
mothers carry the keys to our souls with
them all their lives
whoever respects his mother will not
scold someone else's
happiness is the word mother
for children their mom can do the
impossible
only a child knows how much his mother
loves because only he saw her heart from
the inside
labor Is wealth land is its mother
[Music]
to find your love create a new life
in the eyes of your mother you are the
most beautiful child
foreign
but I love the one who gave me this life
more
motherhood is the most difficult of jobs
[Music]
only after we grow up do we appreciate
the value of Mother's advice
better my blood on the floor than a
mother's tear on her cheek
mom is a travel tangle in your life take
care of her
[Music]
the older I get the more often I want to
be in my childhood and in the arms of my
mother
[Music]
mom's love is a garden in which the sun
always shines and the season is always
spring
[Music]
moms never die they just stop being
around
[Music]
a mother is your first friend your best
friend your Forever friend
when you were looking at your mother you
were looking at pure love
mother is the heartbeat in the home
without her there is no heartthrob
[Music]
mothers are Like Glue even when you
can't see them they're still holding the
family together
[Music]
a mother understands what a child does
not say
[Music]
there is no role in life that is more
essential than that of motherhood
motherhood is the Exquisite
inconvenience of being another person's
everything
[Music]
a mother's hug lasts long after she lets
go
only mothers can think of the future
because they give birth to it in their
children
a mother is always the beginning she is
how things begin
[Music]
we are born of love love is our mother
all that I am or ever hope to be I owe
to my mother
when you look at your mother you are
looking at the purest love you will ever
know
there is no way to be a perfect mother
but a million ways to be a good one
there is no velvet so soft as a mother's
lap no rose as lovely as her smile no
path as flowery as that worn by her
footsteps
laughs
[Music]
a mother is clothed with strength and
dignity laughs without fear of the
future when she speaks her words are
wise and she gives instructions with
kindness
[Music]
motherhood all love begins and ends
there
[Music]
an ounce of mother is worth a pound of
priest
Mother Love is the fuel that enables a
normal human being to do the impossible
of all the rights of women the greatest
is to be a mother
[Music]
a mother is a person who seeing that
there are only four pieces of pie for
five people promptly announces she never
did care for pie
[Music]
children are the anchors that keep a
mother alive
[Music]
the best mother is the one who replaces
the father when he is gone
motherhood is higher than love
whoever does not respect her mother
loses all respect for herself
[Music]